[Music]
this morning a special edition of the
dish as we all know from history class
the love of spices once sent ships
sailing halfway around the globe and
spices still play an essential role in
cuisines around the world here in New
York we met up with Lee or Lev circars
he's a superstar of seasoning who's
spicing up the dishes of both restaurant
kitchens and inspired home chefs his new
book out this fall is called mastering
spiced recipes and techniques to
transform your everyday cooking I wake
up in the morning I put some in my tea
in my coffee in my the self-proclaimed
king of spices you put spices in your
tea and coffee they do can't help
creating flavors beyond the ordinary
it's exciting I put it in water even
throughout the day in a bottle of water
I put some chef Lior loves to car says
it's just in his nature it smells so
good right now what is it about spice
spices are a one of the most important
things in in the culinary world but also
in the world because it's it's a rare
ingredient that touches everybody then
to me it was a happy place because it
connected me all the time to food that
connection has led to a very successful
business his blends which can include up
to 23 and spices are sought after by
some of the world's most famous chefs
including Eric repair and Daniel Boulud
spicy title it was a good boy it was a
good boy very passionate very serious
very committed and at the same time leo
is an artist an artist whose medium
ranges between nature there's really no
limits on what you can do with these
blends and nurture I like this one yeah
so this is a blend of a different
peppers
fruity too floral the hints of the
citrus are just boom-boom piney too
pungent mmm Oh call me that time blends
curated at times to the tastes of each
customer we spent quite a bit of time
with each person that comes here to
ask him some simple questions you know
what do you cook what do you like what
you don't like we have them smell and
taste a bunch of spices it's interesting
because often they'll say oh I don't
care much for this and they'll end up
buying it really what because they have
a pre notion of something that they
don't like let's say celery seeds I
usually ask them who did something wrong
to your celery in the past what happened
to you in celery
Lior lives the cars was born in Israel
which is where he started cooking
professionally but he spiced up his life
after a move to France while training
with michelin-starred chef Olivier
Rowland Jay he wasn't still he's very
influential in my life and my my career
cooking and spices he was very smart in
in the idea of explaining to me that the
spices that he was using were just a
tool the same way that he had a great
knife or cutting board and he said I
want you to develop your own personality
when it comes to taste scent and flavor
by tasting these things and I'll be here
to help you along the journey that
journey ultimately took him to New York
City to work for chef balloon but after
six years and with balloons blessing he
realized he could pursue a food career
without being tied to a kitchen what was
it about the kitchen you didn't like I
never liked the service aspect of it and
that slowly convinced me that perhaps I
need to keep on developing food flavors
and scent but outside of that
environment you gave him an incredible
piece of advice which was hey the
cooking isn't all there is for the
restaurant business
clearly leo will always be a chef I
think he saw this opportunity to be able
to remain a chef and very involved with
the commitment of creating foods and
making food starting over meant blending
in his basement for the first few years
then in 2011 he finally opened his own
storefront labott in New York City what
he came to realize just like in the
world of food there is always more to
master in the spice world how much have
you explored in
the realm of spice can you say a hundred
percent no way I fortunately just came
back from India after twelve years in
the business one of the most important
moments was for me to stand in the
equivalent of 50 football fields where
they trade chilies on a daily basis it
took me back to basics and I knew a lot
already so when you ask me how much do I
know I don't know if I can quantify it
but I don't know that I'm even halfway
to where I want to be and that's amazing
is this the new frontier in the world of
culinary cuisine
I think forleo what was important is to
first source unique spice cumin is cumin
but maybe the equipment from a certain
region of a certain country is better
and then from that is to be able to
create simple and unique blends who will
be almost a trademark to him these
blends but we will connect with the chef
mine circars still does business with
his old boss he's now just one of his
best customers
chef Baloo uses those blends in
everything from his chicken tagine and
when we say spicy it's not hot spicy to
cocktail this cocktail has been made
with gin which is a collaboration with
Leo and the gin has been made with some
Indonesian berries and some mint from
Israel whoa Cheers cheers to you oh my
it's perfect where do you go from here
the unbelievably exciting thing for me
in the last 12 years is that there's no
day that's the same I don't know who's
gonna call and who I'm gonna meet chefs
and pastry chefs and chocolate makers
and beer brewers and distillers and
champagne makers it's so exciting and
the opportunities are endless you know
you can liven up your a cooking because
once a month he holds a class at his
storefront labott and you got a book
early though because they go it's yeah
it really is you know I I did a spice
blend I was like you know Italy or
anything with cayenne pepper that's you
salt
and black pepper I'm good with it that
is you it's amazing because it really
does change the whole flavor of food I'm
a little jealous though you had the the
toast there with Danielle oh yeah it's
time for a toast now Jeff Oreo though we
normally have a chance to host because
of the dish regulars it is your first
Saturday with us for the week our
signature yeah cheers guys having me
thank you
Cheers mmm YUM I could do this every
week